one I wouldn't [__] put anywhere on
this goddamn list is a race another
incredibly overrated show in my opinion
how the hell is this so high it it it is
one of the wonders of the universe that
this man managed to get a show this high
up I it just baffles my mind that there
were literally 2 million people on Mal
who watched a race got to the ending and
went ain't no way like it wasn't the
most obvious [__] thing on the planet
for the show is insane that
is it's insane because two million
[__] like dude yeah I mean it was
pretty popular when it aired back in the
day um I think the problem with a you
know sometimes you're like oh it's not
about the destination it's about the
journey problem is the race is when you
set up a mystery like a race and that
mystery just does not you have to land
you know I don't care if I get to the
wrong station occasionally but if if my
[__] train lands in a [__] crater
and I die then that I would consider
that you fumble the B you fumble the end
you know what I mean it's ASA not ascar
it's as ascar yeah it should be my girl
not my girl yeah I mean Ren came Ren
came out like uh much so if you do now
you got to way Ram just Ram yeah just
ram ram and then past past 12 months
change that to like all time yeah yeah
let's see what it's like uh
2004 because then we should see Ashton
higher Ain no way ain't no way what the
[__] wait that can't be right wait oh no
Rand is probably talking about like the
band or like rap eye movement and then
search to how do you re zero how I don't
know oh yeah there go there you go the
bottom at the bottom yeah there we go
okay so we should okay oh there we go
that makes more sense okay yeah look it
never it never passed it never passed
arsena wow not a single time it passed
arsa all right I was I was like I was
like sweating for a second I was
like I was like everything I know is
your Supremacy has been this whole time
may maybe I am full of
[__] okay anyway let's go back anyway
anyway
let's get back to the list uh another
one which baffles my [__] mind we
should do most popular W next oh my God
going to kill you guys all [__] on it
I'm here to defend it all right all
right please enlighten me it's not bad
why why is it not bad I kind of liked it
uh I also was uh I like did you did you
have uh What uh how old were you when
you watch it how old were you when you
watch was like
7 I've been how old was I in 2014 July I
would have been I would just turned
[__] 17
right no sorry what am I saying I can't
math bro yeah you're born you're I would
have been 18 18 yeah yeah so I think to
me I was like yeah this show is for me I
also I also like that he was [__] the
main
girl look it's okay I liked elf and Lead
when it came it's the same thing this is
this is the same [__] I think CU it's
like it did it did it copied Halo Reach
I'm saying
and Halo is fine I I the thing about Kam
a kill is like I can understand why
teenagers [__] I [__] as a te you
think this is deep because yo they're
killing off characters oh my God this is
so deep I can't tell what would happen
who going to die next ain't no way it's
that girl it was dumb fun and
unfortunately the worst part of the show
is akame uh she's [__] boring I mean
most of the characters are boring in my
opinion oh I like some of them main
characters boring as [__] I mean if I
the main character is hentai main
character material I mean if I remember
most of the characters I felt were just
like I didn't even get enough time to
know them before they just got killed
off which was like the big thing which
was just like oh this is just this
person is just a Trope haha sad
backstory admittedly when I when I
started watching ARA kill and I didn't
know anything about it it was just
another seasonal show that I decided to
start watching like when they did start
killing off the first couple of
characters I was like oh okay this is
cool okay this this might go somewhere
and then every second episode they're
killing off I'm
like it was the one weakness of it is
that you knew it was coming because they
set it up so that it kept happening got
very quickly kind of wish you didn't do
that but it was it was it started strong
and I I I as much as I like the show cuz
I watch as a teenager I wouldn't put it
in top 100 it doesn't deserve to be on
this is the show that you go to as a 14
to 18 year old Le I've outgrown that
yeah I can make a kill yeah I can make a
kill Mirai Nikki Elfin lead they're all
the same you know they're all the same
they're all the same talking about angel
Beats uh I mean in some some senses I
think this is a classic but in other
senses I think it's rated far too high I
think I yeah the only re I I mean I have
a lot of nostalgia for this show
obviously and I have a lot of bias as a
maid Jun fan um I personally really
liked it do I think it's maid jun's best
work no uh but I I mean I don't know
number 30 is a tough spot yeah cuz it's
kind of like it's good good but it's not
but it's acknowledging that it's not the
best right because it is a solid show
solid I think I would be okay with it at
30 but I probably would put it lower but
I think I'm okay with it I would put
that I would put it lower because I
think
that's I think that's uh the ending to
me it felt like you had a really good
run and then it just ended fumbled and
then 13 episode wasn't enough I I think
it should have been more let's uh speed
off a little bit s at 31 above mob
psycho it gives me an annur that is kind
of wild that
it's it was that popular seven deadly
sins when it when it was airing was so
popular that's crazy it was so so
popular and season 2 when they
introduced escanor it only got even more
popular everyone was [__] on board
everyone was hyped even though mot is
the worst protagonist of all time yeah
and thenon [__] the bed yeah which
honestly it feels like a fitting end for
motus as a character who is a dog [__]
character to be treated as dog [__] by
the animators uh it feels fitting never
understood the appeal of seven deadly
sins to begin with um that and I have
not watched I've not watched the second
season but I've watched the first season
it took me a lot to get through this
first season
[__] you know what I'm seeing I'm seeing
AKA kill seven deadly sins and now Mirai
Nikki and I'm like ah the 14-year-old
Army is strong where fairy tale the only
thing that's missing is fairy tale we
all we all know that mob psyo should be
much higher mob psyo is good and I think
is one of the best modern to come out
period uh I think it's the best anime
maybe of the 20 like of the 20 last
decade yeah one of the best animes of
the last decade uh Niki above
assassination classroom is [__] wild
that is a show that uh just did
something that no other show did at the
time and and you know they cemented the
yandere Trope that is true and they they
did it so they committed so fully to the
yandere Trope before anyone else did and
it was kind of like almost reol in that
sense it was a bad Nikki ruined an
entire generation of boys oh yeah oh
[__] oh yeah it did convince me that
it was like yeah maybe she's worth it
maybe I will ruin my life for her I
think Mira Nicki is like the point zero
of the IC can fixer like boy Mir Nikki
made everybody forget the age old saying
of don't stick your dick in crazy it
turned from don't stick your dick in
Crazy to I can fix her this is this is
this is the hurting point this is the
Canon event of this like real life law
where boys were like I can fix it but
man from a con conceptual level what a
[__] cool idea for a show I [__]
really liked it again really cool idea
for a show I enjoyed watching it a lot I
had a lot of fun with it I I can see why
it's 33 but yeah I mean yeah I just
think it was especially in the second
half it just got a little bit too try
Hardy for me yeah it took itself way too
seriously assassination classroom okay I
personally pretty happy with
assassination classroom being on here
because I think this is constantly
underrated in terms of a show and show I
think not a lot of people think about
assassination classroom when they think
of shown in shows but I think
assassination CLA is a really solid show
I'm happy to have it up there I really
enjoy I've not seen it so but I've not
really heard anyone say anything bad
about it or that it's
overrated it's line to what the [__] we
don't talk don't talk about that highq
this is the highest rated Sports Anime I
guess or most popular sports anime on
yeah I think I think the only modern
Sports Anime I prefer over hiq not
counting pingpong League animation is
probably haimo IO but hiq I think okay
the difference between haq and hajim
Mano is that the characters in hajim
Mano are just [__] ugly you know it's
just like you boxing bro the C are ugly
and it is an older mang as well okay
there's that but okay you you compare
the characters in hajo IO like the
[__] it's like comparing Wayne Rooney
to Cristiano Ronaldo you know what I
mean that's such a British
reference it's it's like there's this
one man who has been molded with [__]
testosterone and then there is like the
perfect specimen of like Who had who
could probably be like a [__] K-pop
Idol if he wanted to be you know that's
like haimo versus uh hiq that's true
yeah I haven't seen hiq yet so I I can't
see anything about it I would like to
get into it you know I although I kind
of fell out of it I I can understand why
it's was very popular and being there
I've only heard good things about it
promise Neverland holy [__] dog L
promise Neverland dog L dog [__] L bro
that's yeah are you serious I did not
[__] with it I thought okay wait wait
wait wait why uh because they set up
this really cool mystery and then it
turned out to be stupid and not fun and
season 2 was the worst thing I've ever
watched in my life okay but this is
talking about season one and I think I'm
thinking about the show as a whole you
watch season 2 I watched a little bit
and I was like I'm I'm out I mean yeah
show definitely fumbled the bag in
season 2 but if we're just talking
season one which is what this position
is I thought the first 12 episodes of
Promise Neverland were pretty solid is
it is the best written like horror
mystery you know Supernatural show no I
only had like I think it's pretty
[__] damn good my my okay my biggest
problem F yeah my biggest problem with
promis Neverland was never the mystery
aspect of it cuz I do think it was a
pretty damn good mystery and has one of
the best hooks one of the best hooks in
episode one I think
um it was just the fact that it threw my
suspension of disbelief to its absolute
limits these kids are 12 yeah these kids
are 12 and there is like some plot
points at the end of season 1 where I'm
like you remember what that's possible
it would have worked a little better if
they were just like four or five years
older yeah I think it would have all
tied together more same thing with um
Tokyo Avengers yeah just yeah uh I I
feel like season 2 had potential if it
didn't skip some of the best arcs in the
manga I do think the manga fell off a
bit in the ending but for the most part
it's pretty damn good all right and then
we have OG bleach which I guess we've
already talked
about that I'm I'm happy with that I
think I think 40 it probably be in my
top 25 I think I would yeah probably put
a little bit higher um season one was
[__] awesome and a great introduction
to the series blue exist and blue exist
but this is again this show was so so
popular in the W was it yeah I I have
never had a I I've saying this I've
never had a conversation with anyone
about blue exist I was in the Black
Butler fandom all right I'm telling you
trust me this show was was was very
popular with that same Tumbl carrying
again was this a Tumblr show it was huge
on Tumblr yeah this was this was like a
really really popular show uh you know
way way back but this was also an
incredibly popular show in Japan as well
oh really this was massive in Japan when
it came out uh and I think look I don't
hate the show I just think it's the most
like
okay mid I I'll say it is mid yeah it's
pretty mid it's not [__] but it's not
like number 41 I'm not saying mid in
like how do I say I'm not saying mid
derogatory term I'm saying it is bog
standard average it's in the middle it's
a 7.5 on Mal which is literally the
five pretty much for [__] sake just
call
sake okay why would they call this
what's wrong with you a lot of people
liked parasite I thought I love parasite
you love parasite I [__] with it so much
sell me on parasite okay first of all
dubstep Conor that's music how can you
tell how you but dubstep is the most
beeps and boobs you have music I've
watched these fights in [__] narrow
to one piece I'm
[__] that
[__] I was like
um the fact that uh I don't know I just
[__] with it I thought it was such a
cool idea I thought it was so [__]
fun I think yeah I think the one thing I
appreciate the most about the parasite
anime is just how much they decided to
deviate from the original manga but
still did it in a solid way my favorite
part is when he [__] becomes cool and
swag when I I was going to say this this
did Tokyo Ghoul before he was cool the
[__] all you need to do is just yes
but that's what I appreciate it right
cuz in the original manga he starts off
swag there's no transformation so like
the fact that they in the anime they
decided to like kind of start him off as
this like wimpy scared confused
character to then upon the development
get him to be more confident in was
interesting I just remember I just
really really enjoyed parasite I
remember had a lot of fun with it yes
the dub step was kind of annoying and I
wish they had gone with a different
direction but I still had so much fun
and the concept was cool Al concept was
I really really love the concept con was
well I will say uh I am upset that the
anime missed out on my favorite panel in
the manga where migy turns into a giant
[__] so that is that I I was looking
forward to that and they cut that [__]
out I honestly would like it a little
bit higher be like my top 30 because to
me the opening is Banger oh the opening
is Banger I think I'm like the one
person that just didn't [__] with it I I
I didn't dislike it I just don't
remember there were like no scenes in
that that I really remember or really
like hit me and I don't know if I was
just in the wrong place to watch it I
was just like eh it's fine it's this was
like my norami I guess well like I it's
I don't understand I just realized that
cowel and even gallion are both in the
40s yeah that's crazy and Spirited Away
H Spirit movies don't get rated as as
good on
theu I am so shocked that cowo b and
even gallion are that low yeah I would
have expected them to be at least in the
top 20 I'm surprised that parasite is
more
popular that's wild that is crazy but I
guess cuz I think people who watch
parasite really [__] fell in love
with it um whereas people who watch C I
feel like almost watch it out of
obligation and almost saying again it's
it's a social media website right so
saying oh yeah C was one of my favorites
it's like okay what else do you like
bread you know what I mean I also have
eyes uh I actually don't some surprised
toky route a is crazy toky route a above
death parade everyone and violet
evergarden fairy tale Ain no way wild
ain't no way what is this this is such a
whack list what the [__] is this you
know what maybe Tumblr dying was uh was
was the right was the right decision
guys CU then we don't have to deal with
[__] like this I can't believe I I never
watched ever gotten it just felt like
crying bait for me so kind of
gorgeous Gorge crying bait my hot take
about Violet ever Garden is that my
favorite parts of violet ever Garden was
the stories that didn't have anything to
do with the main character um I loved
the Side Stories um and that was my
favorite part of V Violet evergarden
death with I will say death prey should
in for me is in the top 20 death should
be way higher be way but you know I will
count it as a w that death parade
somehow beat fairy tale let's go kind of
I I had forgotten about fairy tales I'm
kind of sad that I had to remember it
right now yeah all right